if theresa decides to file for divorce
do you understand why she would do that
listen as long as she's happy you know
that's all that really matters Real
Housewives of New Jersey stars Teresa
and Joe Giudice have officially split
after 20 years of marriage I'm not gonna
you know tell her what to do I can't you
know I mean it's if she doesn't feel
like she wants to be with me anymore
then you know that's nothing to do a
source confirm the split to et on
Tuesday explaining that Teresa has been
living the life of a single mother ever
since Joe was incarcerated dedicating
herself entirely to their four daughters
and her career quote she always knew
there was a possibility that Joe would
get deported but it all happened so fast
after his release what you said was that
if he stays in Italy you could see
divorcing him that you wouldn't stay
together you didn't think that it would
work I don't see it working the source
also told ET that Teresa is very
realistic about the past adding that
she's known for a while that things
weren't going to work out between them
quote their marriage had been through
far too much for them to start over
she's ready for a new start for 2020 DT
has reached out to Teresa and Joe's reps
for comment now there's only one thing
to do make things better and move on he
caught up with Teresa in September where
she told us how her family was doing
during this trying time
you know strong young women I guess they
get it from their mommy yes the reality
star also weighed in on the dramatic
season 10 trailer for The Real
Housewives of New Jersey which had just
dropped at the time and you saw that
what was your reaction to it all play
out the trailer gave viewers a very real
look at her complicated situation with
Joe amid his deportation case I don't
know our families having to deal with
that in the public eye how do you deal
with that I'm used to it yeah
that's what happens when you're on TV
it's a double-edged sword
[Music]